now to the World Cup Where in the past
couple of minutes there has been
heartbreak for Wales they've lost two
nil to Iran that is thanks to two goals
in injury time where we can bring in our
correspondent Aleister bunkel who is
there in Doha for us
um Alistair I was going to start by
talking to you about the softening of
the rules around symbolic protests but I
need to start by asking you about bitter
disappointment for Welsh fans in the
last few moments
[Music]
yeah heart rate for Wales in the last
couple of minutes of the match Iran
scoring two to win it I mean to be
honest a run with a better side for much
of the match Wales had their goal
giveaway and Hennessy uh sent off late
on uh for a very uh dangerous tackle uh
well well outside of the box on one of
the Iranian Players let's get some
immediate reaction I'll try and get some
Welsh fans but uh Iranian who yeah
that's me well done congratulations your
side of have won you're back in it and
you've got a good chance of qualifying
thank you so much we really showed that
we are a good team after that came
against England a lot of people were in
doubt about Iran but we showed that we
are a good team and if we have a good
lineup let's say carish please consider
the good lineup yeah if you consider the
good lineup we can win the game we can
win every game one last quick question
obviously things back home are in a
really bad position at the moment what
does this mean what will this mean for
Iranians back home that the side team
melee have got their win uh
I didn't get your question really what
will it mean for Iranians back home to
get back home no for the people
supporting back home watching this
to see their side winning at the World
Cup uh I hope that people in in Iran get
some energy for uh seeing good days in
Iran really thank you so much
congratulations well done let's try and
grab some Welsh fans
guys
um live on Sky News okay we're gonna
just um push on I can understand how a
few Wells fans are probably pretty uh
not in the mood to talk let's see
whether we can ask guys sorry live on
Sky News your reaction to the wind we
lost sorry reaction to the loss of
apologies
reaction to the loss uh [ __ ] apologies
for the language uh that's inevitable
sometimes with situations like this live
on television look I will say that you
know the Iranian fans I'm the Welsh fans
who we spend a lot of the day with from
very early on when they were gathering
on the Corniche here in Doha were really
anticipating a win against Iran they'll
have seen the fact that England scored
six against them Wales needed this win
to progress their task now is in a way
pretty simple in one sense they've got
to beat England but on paper that is far
from simple having said that when they
meet on Tuesday the two home Nations
coming together who knows what might
happen they will still be here they will
still be supporting that team with every
bit as much passion and they'll hope
that that can swing the tide in their
favor but it has not gone wells's way
today Becky some of those Lads were
really hoping for some excitement in the
match it won't be the kind of excitement
that they were looking for
oh it's just gone from bad to worse
happened to in the last uh 20 minutes or
so of that game with first the
goalkeeper Hennessy being sent off and
then of course those two Iranian goals
um the atmosphere we had here has turned
really to a quiet dejection let's have a
word with one or two of the people here
watching it excuse me Lads um
how are you I mean it's a tough question
really but how are you feeling it's it's
shocking terrible performance throughout
however I feel like if we do we could
try and win the next game sort of repair
the damage that's already been done sort
of thing and yeah
I mean everyone was so hopeful you
really thought they were going to get
the win today didn't you yeah I mean
everyone was hyped you know he was
singing a national anthem you saw the
passion in everyone it's just it's just
so sad that we lost you know it's just I
mean theoretically a winner against
England and you're still in it do you
still got hopes or not really I got hope
I hope the players they gave 100 I think
they always do for Wales
um but we'll see what happens tonight
with England and USA it's usab England
then it's all on the cards but we can we
can only just pray that the results go
our way but I think even though we lost
they put in a good shift and that's all
we can hope for as Wales fans
you guys have got to go back to lessons
now so uh yes no not many Smiles on
faces here good good luck guys but um
yeah let's bring in PA teacher
well not much to say about the last 20
minutes or so oh extremely disappointed
we just didn't play on the day but being
a Welshman I'm the eternal optimist and
uh again you want to hear Wells from see
this often but we want England to win
tonight to give us a chance
in theory in theory whales could still
stay in it if you beat England yeah and
hopefully if England win tonight they
will need to play their their top player
so they'll rest them for the well
smashed so who knows but we need to play
a lot better it's unusual to hear a
Welsh man say he wants England to win it
goes against the grain massively but we
need him to do us a favor tonight Nicole
Tommy Wilson former people here everyone
he did start but was brought off nobody
came out with Nicole Williams was an
accident but no I think they all need to
realize he wasn't good enough and
they've got weapon for the next match
but you never know the Welsh government
like what allowed schools to get
people's time off is it's back to
lessons now with Glenn faces I think
there'll be quite a few blunt faces now
but we've got to try and get him back on
track now yeah all right well thanks so
much for letting us watch the game with
you guys thank you
yeah so uh yeah really um huge amount of
disappointment here and now really uh
all eyes on what happens with the rest
of the group games and just keeping
their fingers crossed but of course I
don't think many people here think that
it's possible that Wales could beat
England but look you never know you
never know in indeed the disappointment
very large there amongst the people at
that school where Becky is thank you